I might Ilana the coffins have two more
of the victims of this bloody week were
taken this afternoon for burial more
than a hundred are confirmed to have
died in the five days of protests for
charities and human rights agencies say
the actual figure is higher and
thousands have been injured the streets
in Baghdad and elsewhere had been
quieter today just the mess left behind
after moments of serious disorder and
violence tonight though there has been
more like this the security forces
police and the army have been firing
live rounds at protesters as well as
volleys of teargas snipers have also
been seen apparently to take out
individual protesters some of them have
sling shots but most seem only to be
carrying their country's flag the
protesters have been driven by a
profound sense of hopelessness the
people on the streets are young educated
and they're fed up of having a complete
lack of any prospects either master's
degree but the government would not even
hire me as a street sweeper all these
young people are treated unfairly it
does sound like the government might be
listening the Prime Minister tonight
striking what is at face value at least
conciliatory I am ready to go wherever
our brotherly protestors are stationed
and meet them or send them envoys to
other locations and other provinces
without any armed forces I'll go and
meet them without weapons and sits with
them for hours to listen to their
demands the internet was cut but he's
working now although social media is not
reliable an attempt by the authorities
to prevent the protesters from
communicating and coordinating on some
private TV stations were taken offline -
by unidentified masked men the
government hasn't explained why had
apparently ordered its agents to do this
we have not forged reality we
transmitted the truth as it is it seems
that this state cannot bear the truth I
hope that the premier would announce his
star
but he was silent towards what happened
60% of Iraq's population is under 25
they're calling simply for their country
to function the basic services to work
the government accountability and an end
to corruption it is 16 years since a
Western coalition Elstad Saddam Hussein
since then Iraq has been framed by waves
of violence they fought foreign powers
each other the Islamic state and now the
young here just want a viable future
Mark Stone Sky News
[Applause]